foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we talk about your
life specifically your money your work
your relationships it is a free phone
call to jump in AAA
825-5225 I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel and as I said this is where
we unpack your big questions the small
questions the medium-sized questions
there's no bad question here because
this entire focus of this show is about
you getting breakthrough in the form of
Hope through practical steps forward
whether that be again in your debt and
financial life or I'm here today to tell
help you through some work issues maybe
you're dealing with a toxic leader or
toxic environment or you've got some
opportunities you're not sure should I
take it can I actually change jobs to
change careers in the baby steps the
answer is yes and so George and I are
here for you George you doing well today
you look
particularly uh fall themed today I like
it take fall aesthetic just for you Ken
I you look like you could blend right
into the uh lovely warm brown tones of
the studio wow I noticed earlier today
the audience can't see it but your boots
Match Your Shirt and your glasses and
they say men don't notice so I got well
I tell you you just look like fall thank
you and we're glad that falls here by
the way I want to just mention this very
quickly we'll get to your phone calls
shortly uh we are headed to Dallas Texas
I looked up at the calendar
and uh we will head out on Friday the
whole crew the entire Ramsay personality
crew we're going to be coming to Dallas
for uh smart conference I'm sure I'll be
talking about that later in the program
but I got very excited about that and
that's going to be a one of a kind day
uh we're very very excited all of us
there speaking and I'm excited for your
talk Ken which a very different talk for
you but very inspiring nonetheless well
I'm going to be addressing the issue of
waiting on your World to Change you know
and you think about uh
people's Financial issues you know I
think very succinctly of the person who
is just sitting there right now and baby
step one go on I don't even know how I'm
gonna get to a thousand dollars or
they're in baby step two and they're
going okay I believe this works
uh I want it to work
but it feels like it's gonna take me
forever and five seven eight years is
what it looks like it feels like and
they're exhausted they're exhausted
emotionally they're exhausted physically
some exhausted spiritually you know I
think of people and marriages that are
fighting for everything they got we took
a call the other day when we were on
together and I said to the I said to the
man I said I'd fight with everything you
got I've got friends that have gone
through divorce and that's what they've
told me they wish they would have fought
with everything they have for that
marriage what's that old quote when
you're at the end of the rope tie a
knife hang on it's from Franklin Delano
Roosevelt
FDR quote all FDR and so we're going to
be talking about that at smart
conference you know you're waiting on a
kid
a prodigal son to come home you know
um and so what does it take to wait
how do you summon the willpower to wait
so that's just the one thing we're
talking about you're going to be talking
about I'm talking about how to find that
margin because so many calls we take
people are going I don't have enough
money at the end of the month to cover
my bills to do the baby steps and so I'm
going to show them very tactically how
to do that and do a live every dollar
budgeting demo which I know sounds as
thrilling uh as can be you might want to
wear a Steve Jobs kind of outfit a
little turtleneck yeah to do a product
demo 6 000 people you doing in an arena
it's a risky move yes it is uh well
George and I are always glad to be by
the way I don't read the comments but
George does he has deep neurotic
problems and and uh he reads the
comments on YouTube and all other places
but apparently some people like our uh
our combo so we're gonna try to serve
you well one listener said root beer
float we were like a root beer float
great ingredients on their own little
vanilla ice cream and root beer but when
put together some pure magic and that's
ruined me because now that I know that I
feel the pressure to be as good as a
root beer float every day you wake up
you gotta go can I be a root beer float
and I'm afraid we've already failed but
let's get to the phones we're gonna go
wow globally am I reading that right
we're going to Finland where atesh is
joining us atash how can we help
hey guys hey thanks for calling Mike
like taking my calls like it's crazy I'm
a little bit excited but I really
appreciate what time is it there attest
uh what time is it it's uh 9pm like just
over 9 p.m wow got you right before
bedtime I must tell you this is the
first time I've ever talked to anybody
in Finland so I'm equally excited what's
your question well
um hey okay uh so I'm planning to get
into a mortgage
um
so basically
um I I try to stick to your plan and I
try to find like a mortgage deal that
would fit to like uh take 25 of my
income you know I think that's what you
guys suggesting
um so but I think I feel like I can go a
little bit more than that
and because in Finland we don't
necessarily need to put any say my money
into uh
401k or college funds for kids you know
things are pretty stable in terms of
here like I pay like 25 tax based on my
income
taxes are pretty high yeah would you
still suggest me to go up to like 30 35
like I like the car loan and no other
debts
well atesh I'll tell you this before you
become a homeowner
becoming completely debt free is going
to free you up in a big way and so I
would not jump into this mortgage until
that car loan is paid off
I see so I have like seven thousand
Euros
a car loan and that's like that's going
to take three and a half years and I
have like 9 000 Euros in savings right
now okay hold on you got the money why
not just pay it off today
well I can pay it off but then for the
model like mortgage down payment I can
actually like well that means that
you're just actually starting from you
know Ground Zero here this is a
financial Foundation right now on paper
it looks like you have money but you
don't because you owe that car lender
and if you don't believe me stop paying
the payments see if they don't take the
car away
well that's true but like I I don't know
like how old are you I might be like
kind of 26 26. okay so let's say it's
going to take you a little while longer
to save up the down payment so what yeah
I would need like five thousands like
five like six thousand Euros per down
payment it sounds like you're putting
very little down what's this house gonna
cost
like I'm thinking of something like 120
000 if it's with Max you know because
the euro is about the same as the dollar
right now
it is but the amount of money we make
here is completely different than the US
when I listen to the show you know like
what do you make I I like I make like 2
700 cash in a month you know okay which
is okay in Finnish standards you know
yeah
that's making thirty two thousand Euros
a year right
yeah that's right which is essentially
32 000 American and here I'd say you
need more income if you're going to be a
homeowner
um okay maybe I mean I see my friends
doing this thing you know well your
friends broke it sounds like they're
broke then
well like I don't know maybe they may
not look like all right so George is
being very nice attesh here's the deal
you need to pay the car off today it's
going to leave you 2 000 Euros left over
still need an emergency fund you still
need the emergency fund but you need to
walk this thing up because you're gonna
have less expenses once that car is paid
off which means you can save more and
you need to relax you're still a young
man don't rush into the house until you
can afford it this is just math I don't
care if it's pesos Euros whatever you
want to call it you don't get a pass on
math and so I want you to do things the
wise way you're 26 you get the rest of
your life ahead of you just be patient
slow down and if your friends are doing
dumb things doesn't mean you should do
them means find better friends
yeah I like that advice Jordan there you
go hey don't move we're just getting
warmed up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show so
excited you've joined us America I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell and we
always enjoy being together because we
love to help people that's you the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll talk about your money questions
and I'm in today I host the Ken Coleman
show as part of the Ramsey Network
specifically helping people win in their
work you spend more time at work than
you do anything else in your life and I
think you should make plenty of money
but I also think you should experience
tremendous meaning and um I'm also about
helping you make more income so if
you've been with us for a while we were
we kind of refer to your income as a
shovel so the more income the bigger the
shovel getting out of debt getting
through the baby steps so I'm here to
help out on that particular area of
focus as well so give us a call I'm
willing to help and George is always in
control looking very first of today in
his fall get up at Terminal if you will
autumnal right I see what you did there
Autumn and then you changed it up so uh
for those of you who like to watch us on
YouTube you can see George is looking uh
particularly that's the reason they're
tuning in Ken I will it might be uh if
you want to see a little man in very
nice fall attire uh with a finely
trimmed beard it's a perk no one else
see now they gotta see what you look
like if they've never seen what you look
like now they want to know all these
guys listen on radio are like I gotta
watch YouTube they do yeah so it's on
demand check out the Ramsey show all
right grant is going to join us out in
Atlanta Georgia Grant how can we help
hey so I bought a truck back in December
and I financed it and the engine blew up
last month
if I want to get rid of it or if I need
to stick to it well tell us more about
the truck with I I'm I'm assuming it was
a used truck
it was a used truck
um it had not too many miles on it but
um there was an issue with the engine
and now it's sitting in my driveway dead
did you throw a rod
um
uh the main bearings on the crankshaft
spun
have you talked to anybody about what
that would cost to fix is that a total
uh like pulling the engine out can it be
repaired is it a whole new engine
um from the people that I've talked to
it's it sounded like it's a whole new
engine because it's actually damaged the
block that's what I was worried about
now George I know you don't know
anything that we just no idea what we do
beyond the clutch pack piston I'm
useless yeah yeah yeah George the only
thing George knows about a car is
there's a catalytic converter he doesn't
even know what that does I always ask if
there's a Hemi
so but I do know this grant right I know
math and so that's something we can dive
into to see if this is worth so what's
the yeah so what's the engine going to
cost a new engine so so just doing a
little bit of research a new engine is
about eight thousand dollars okay what'd
you pay for the truck
uh I'm paid well I financed um 36 000.
well
so what is this thing worth in the
condition it's in you think
uh on a good day maybe 20.
with the engine as is
I think so I I'm not you see that's
that's where I'm kind of in the middle
of like I don't know if it's gonna well
Georgia and I are we're not experts on
that so you're gonna have to do multiple
cross-referencing on that and get an
idea what that truck is worth with an
engine that needs to the key is if you
if you put the new engine in it would it
would you recoup the cost on that
I'm not sure because I think with labor
and all I think it's probably going to
be about twelve thousand dollars to
repair it easy
which would bring its value to what do
you think back to where it was uh
realistically if I was trying to try and
sell it privately I could probably get
maybe 32 33 out of it okay so you'd
still be underwater on top of paying for
the repair
yeah man that stinks where'd you buy it
from
I bought it from one of my local GMC
dealerships okay and is it out of
warranty on the engine
well so they they offered an extended
warranty for six thousand dollars so I
declined that because I didn't want to
have I didn't want to be upside down you
know forty two thousand dollars
but is there a manufacturer warranty on
the engine beyond the dealerships
possibly uh possibly
um I haven't fully looked into that I've
more been just kind of figuring out what
engines are going to cost
um
I would double check that I don't have
high hopes for that but certainly worth
looking it's certainly worth the amount
of time spent yeah how old is the truck
uh so 2016 so it's only six years old
okay yeah I mean you might you might
have some luck there because some of
these uh warranties from the actual
manufacturer uh will cover I'd call the
dealer they're they're going to tell you
pretty quickly
I'd call the dealer and say hey here's
what happened is there is there a manuf
do I have any hope at all uh with help
from the manufacturer well they're
saying do all the research and homework
you can before you sink any money into
this thing
yeah and that's that's the good news is
that I haven't I've pretty much got it
to back to my house and it's sitting not
another unfortunate thing is I'm still
making payments on it while I just did
of course do you have the cash to to pay
for the repairs if it's about 12 Grand
um I I had don't have the full amount
for it but my dad said he'd help me out
a little bit so we might be able to uh
Fork out
um what are you doing for what are you
doing for the other vehicle how are you
getting around
um I'm just borrowing one of my parents
Vehicles okay what's your income
I believe it's about 40
4
000 a year and you're driving a truck
that was worth that
yeah no not the not the Ramsey method I
don't think that's any method that's
just a recipe for disaster man and now
we're sitting in this mess and you know
I'm not here to beat you up but just on
the side of even if you fix this car
it's still way too much truck for you
with your income what do you do for a
living yeah
I work at Hertz Rent a Car okay what
other skills do you have where you could
pick up a part-time job nights and
weekends making some pretty decent money
even if you got to go stock shelves at
Walmart for 18 bucks an hour what can
you do
um well I've been looking at getting a
welding job nice uh you know
manufacturing place do you have the
current qualifications for that
I do okay so that's why I asked if you
can if you're qualified you have to
spend any money on getting qualified you
can go makes much better money whether
it's side hustle uh part-time job that
kind of stuff where you have no outlay
at all no money out like you're just
gonna go make more money
George I I'm curious to know what your
opinion is but I I'm gonna go bust it
and go get the 12 000. exactly fix the
truck and unload it so I'm going to cash
flow the repairs unload the truck and if
I still got four thousand dollars
difference you can go borrow that from a
with a personal loan at your credit
union it's the only time we would ever
say it's okay to go into debt is to
clean up a mess like this on something
you're underwater on and so if you can
get a small if you can get a four
thousand dollar loan instead of a 36
well now we're a lot closer to climbing
out of the hole and then we can
aggressively attack that smaller one so
that's what I want you to do your
homework on is how can I get this repair
done for as little money as possible how
can I sell it for as much money as
possible private party is probably going
to be your best bet and then how do we
get out of this mess of debt and find us
a reasonable used car that we can pay
for in cash
so those are the steps to take it's an
easier said than done you've got some
work ahead of you but you can climb out
of this and it can be a lesson learned
where we go never again am I going to be
in that kind of position yeah and that's
what I want you to hear great it's not
there's no way around this this sucks I
mean it sucks all the way around pretty
badly however you can get out of this
relatively unscathed you really can I
mean it's it's it stinks but you can
really do it you know what I mean you're
gonna have to bust it and hustle it'll
work hard but if you get into a welding
job that pays you well you'll be able to
do this and then it's a lesson learned
and so it's not the end of the world is
what I want you to hear yeah and then
for your next vehicle I'll tell you our
parameters around buying a used car in
cash that's not going to sink you don't
let everything that has Motors in it be
more than 50 of your income so if you
make 40 I don't want you to have more
than 20 tied up in these depreciating
assets you know things like boats and
cars and all that and so you might be
looking at buying a ten thousand dollar
used truck and maybe later on as your
income increases we go all right it's
time to upgrade to the fifteen thousand
dollar truck and one day I want you to
have a real nice truck that you love but
right now this truck has you man this
thing owns you and that's what happens
when we put ourselves in these
precarious situations yeah but you know
it's it's doable you know uh we call it
a stupid tax we've all been there we've
all made mistakes with zeros on the end
yeah and it stings man but if you allow
it to kind of okay I learned a valuable
lesson here uh it was what fun yeah free
with an emergency fund and the car's
paid for you go well that stinks I gotta
buy a new engine that's exactly but then
you yawn and move on with your life yeah
man that's tough stuff thanks Grant you
will get on the other side of this man
appreciate the call all right folks
don't move we got more of the Ramsey
show right around the corner
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
your small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined rather by George Campbell
see I did the joined and George together
so the best of us Ken adjourned by
George Campbell uh it does happen to the
best of us it's a study that you all are
with us the number to jump in on the
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five but it's one of our
favorite parts of the show and we look
out into the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage and we see people
who are here to do a debt free scream
it's Chris and Lauren hello hello how
you guys doing we're doing great yeah
okay good where are you guys in from
Oklahoma City Oklahoma City all right
and neither one of you wearing cowboy
boots I want to point out no I'm from
Montana she's hardly Oklahoma so oh I
like that that's it I've never heard of
Oklahoma I like that phrase that you
that you could use the same thing for
George and I that's true as well so this
is exciting so let's get the numbers how
much debt out of you paid off a little
over one hundred and twenty four
thousand dollars in 16 months in 16
months and what was the range of income
uh we started about 120 000 and got up
to 165. wow what do you guys do for a
living
and I work technology for a school
district oh great so what uh what
happened with the uh increase in pay
some promotions or new gigs or what a
little bit was raises but a lot was just
hustling a lot of uh over I think around
a thousand hours of doordash and
ubereats really yeah we uh sold plasma
um pretty much any way you could make
money we did we sold everything we owned
she thought I was going to sell our dogs
and that kind of got her scared
incredible okay so two things what was
the most lucrative side hustle you would
encourage people to go out and do if
they're trying to pay off some debt uh
overall if you get really good at it
doordash and ubereats you can make a lot
of money doing that
give us an idea because I think people
want to know what the hourly rate after
expenses and fees and all that uh
there's nights where we were making you
know 40 50 bucks an hour wow so yeah we
found the right locations the right
restaurants uh knew what offers to turn
down knew what like delivery places to
not go to so we were very selective with
it but once we got into it we started
making off like we were happy to make 12
bucks an hour and then it got to we're
near the end of it I mean there were
days where I was making over a thousand
dollars based on the weather is that
right yeah I think by the way this is uh
just a little quick side note but I want
your opinion this is why a lot of
restaurants are having a hard time
hiring waiters and waitresses because
they can do door Dash instead absolutely
yeah wow that's incredible there you go
just a little economically well and he
was saying you sold all this stuff where
where are you selling it where was the
most the best place to sell your stuff
uh Marketplace was a really good one
Facebook Facebook Marketplace we got
lucky because it was kind of when they
first started doing shipping so we got a
lot of free shipping out of it
um the time we did have to pay for it we
just added it there people will buy
anything on Marketplace it is shocking
yeah like you think who's gonna buy that
so we had to buy it games that we
weren't even sure if they worked or not
put that on the description and people
were paying 20 bucks for them so yeah
our Nintendo 64 games oh wow good for
you guys you said nothing is going to
stop us from paying off 124 Grand in 16
months so what kind of debt was 124. a
lot of student loans two car loans uh
credit cards personal loan uh pretty
just normal typical stuff wow you were
trying to collect them all yeah we're
going for it yeah so what happened 16
months ago and you said all right no
more we're about ready to get gazelle
intents and pay this off
well we got engaged in 2020 and we went
to premarital counseling they gave us
the Total Money Makeover book shout out
to Crossings Community Church by the way
they gave us the information yeah nice
which we didn't read it but my uh my
friend Cassidy she was a big Dave Ramsey
fan and you know I always thought she
was kind of weird for doing it but uh we
it kind of planted a seed when we got
the book we ended up revisiting it later
on yeah for me it was uh we were best
friends who married best friends they're
here with us right now oh so I saw him
reading a book uh The Total Money
Makeover during work during breaks and
for me that was weird because he was
reading at all like he doesn't read you
don't see that though so yeah it turns
out that was like one of the almost
stipulations of their engagement was
like Hey if we're gonna get married you
need to read this book we need to be on
board with this all that stuff so I saw
him doing that and then it was during
the pandemic all this stuff it was 2020
when we got married
um lots of things were getting canceled
lots of things are getting pushed back
on people we decided we're just gonna
move of our wedding forward like we're
not going to wait for all this stuff to
get canceled we don't know what it's
going to look like in five months let's
just get it over with uh that sounds
terrible but yeah let's just do it we
decided to do it in our backyard and
because of that we saved a lot of money
in the long run but we spent a lot of
money in the short run to make it happen
uh our motto basically became chitcha
charge it we were just putting it on
credit cards wow so by the end of it
after we had uh come back from our
honeymoon we sat down to look at it and
we had spent well over five grand just
like in that last month and with all the
payments already had from student loans
and cars I just we weren't sure like how
much money are we gonna have left after
we make all these payments so I mean 124
000 in 16 months yeah what were you
selling cars well I I work in technology
so I was able to buy some broken devices
resell those online
um that's a good side hustle yeah it was
a really great size if you happen to
have any idea how much money you
generated from selling things to to go
into the 102 twenty four thousand I
think it was about six thousand from
broken devices that Chris sold and then
maybe a thousand from stuff around the
house yeah plasma was about another two
thousand dollars uh doordash was like 20
to 30k almost wow from new deliveries
yeah wow amazing so you guys just didn't
sleep not really I mean there were weeks
there was a week where she went to
London and uh I just decided hey I'm
home alone I got nothing to do so I was
putting in like you know 18 19 hour days
just going to work and then coming home
doing doordash and things like that so
so obviously we're hearing a story of
extreme gazelle intensity yeah and you
guys did it that's a lot yeah instead of
beans and rice we just did beans
couldn't afford the rest yeah the rice
yeah so besides the intensity what would
you all say is the key to getting
through this journey
we were a little bit different on this
but for me it was making goals within
the goal and so breaking out you know
124 000 that's a big number to look at
so it was creating smaller goals and
then pushing to reach those and then
once we accomplished that smaller goal
is celebrating that little win and then
that kind of kept us going for the next
one yeah yeah that was really good for
us here breaking it down
um we didn't do any big celebration it'd
be like hey we just paid off our last
credit card let's go to Qdoba like let's
really splurge on that right and uh it
got to a point where our goal was three
years we looked at her income we're like
here's how much we make here's how fast
we can pay it off and then five months
into it we realized we'd already paid
off over fifty thousand dollars and
we're like this is a time we're gonna go
a little bit bigger on this celebration
than we're getting right back into it
within that first year we paid off a
hundred thousand dollars so we were over
a year and a half ahead of schedule
that's amazing at the end of the first
year but I think oh sorry I gotta assume
a lot of that was the cheerleaders I
mean you have 17 people here to support
you yeah they were asking us questions
all the time the hedricks right there
they were kind of our like coaches
almost like we'd listen to the podcast
while we're doing deliveries but at the
same time like if we had questions we'd
go to them uh for me though I think the
biggest one is when we first started
doing this we were looking at our
expenses and we saw tithing in there and
we're like that's our biggest expense
and it's like you know for a brief
second there it was like if we don't do
this we can pay it off like a lot faster
and luckily she slapped me in the face
and was like no we're paying her tithe
like that's literally yeah she said
that's not optional there's a spiritual
slap in the face yeah so we uh we paid
our tithes and that's why we think
things just really started getting
rolling because we were faithful with it
and then
um a couple months into it we started
feeling guilty because we realized we
weren't tithing on the extra income we
were bringing in it's like you know we
don't have just our salaries anymore
we're bringing all this stuff in and
that's God's money too so we need to do
something with that wow so we made a
back payments on our tithe like to catch
up oh my goodness and all of a sudden
she got a Bonus that she'd never gotten
in her life like at her work so bonus
came in paid for it we're like well this
is awesome like God's taking a blessing
you guys have an awesome story I gotta
tell you I'm exhausted uh in a good way
just listening to you guys uh and how
hard that was but in a word was it worth
it
yeah you got much more out of it than
that deal all right you guys ready we're
about ready to do this we want you to
know we're going to give you a copy of
of The Total Money Makeover to give to
somebody else and then Dave's latest
book baby step Millionaires and uh FPU
for you guys to give to somebody else if
you'd like or take it or train somebody
through we're going to give you all that
to show you our appreciation all right
here we go Chris and Lauren from
Oklahoma City Oklahoma they paid off 124
000. in 16 months make it 120 to 165
000 take it away you two it's time to
hear your debt free screen three two one
there it is very nice George I gotta
tell you I need to go give him a box of
rice my face hurts from smiling it's
time they've earned some rice they just
did beans that's the first time I've
ever heard dead no right sacrifice just
beans well that is what it is all about
they have forever changed their future
what an inspiring couple oh that's why
we do the show don't move more Ramsey
show coming right up
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell we're
here for you this hour thrilled to have
you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
talking about your money your work your
relationships George and I combining
today he's the money expert and I'm the
work guy I don't like saying work expert
I'll call you an export guy white guy
hello man I'm a work guy man of the
people uh thrilled uh as always though
George to be here on the show with you
so you can jump in we'll take your
questions uh every time you hear someone
do their debt free scream like we just
had in our last segment it's because at
some point they say I've had it I'm not
going to live this way anymore and when
you can get mad like that and do what
they did your life is going to change
right now inflation and your credit
cards are killing you
but you've been led to believe that
you're not in control of your money
that's wrong you have to decide to
control what you can control and that's
you your behavior you have the power to
change and Financial Peace University is
going to show you what to change this
course will teach you the proven
step-by-step plan that's helped nearly
10 million people beat debt Master
budgeting and build wealth and you can
do it too
stop letting dad and money stress
control your life say I've had it and
take back your control start Financial
Peace University at ramsesolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU triple eight eight two five five two
two five is the phone number let's go to
Boston Massachusetts George's neck of
the woods
Joe is on the line Joe how can we help
hey guys uh thanks for taking the call
so my wife and I
we're gonna knock it down
from General Contractors for the work
and as you can probably imagine they
were they were pretty high
um so we decided to kind of take on the
job ourselves and GC it ourselves wow
but the uh well we didn't work but so
this is all new learning for us right we
don't we're not contractors we're not in
the trade so it's kind of a learning
experience one of the things we learned
is that Banks won't Finance construction
jobs unless you're using a GC
um and so
we found kind of an untraditional loan
through Private Business
um which you know is a little unique
but now we're gonna you know do we
do we go back and work with the GC and
take out kind of more debt to build this
or should we continue down this path
um
of financing you know this untraditional
route and then kind of working through
it on our own I know it's kind of a
unique question but just wondering if
you've seen this before
did you finance the purchase of the home
as well
uh no we paid in cash okay but now we're
financing the the work that needs to be
done how much are we talking about
well so we we sold our house prior to
this
um
and we we cleared a lot of equity in it
so we were able to buy the house uh you
know with cash and we still have a
couple hundred thousand in cash on hand
for the build so the we're thinking
about you know somewhere in the like two
to three hundred grand financing range
so on top of the cash you still need
another 300 Grand in financing
I mean that would be the high end all in
kind of everything
is it too late to back out of the
financing or are you already in this
thing no no we're not okay we're not I'm
wondering if we just move at the speed
of cash because it's going to take a
while to build this thing so could you
start with what you got for the next six
months nine months and then start cash
flowing the rest later on
yeah I guess that's something we haven't
um that hadn't considered I mean it was
always uh
um since taking the finance group but
yeah I mean I guess
that's that would be my plan because it
takes a little bit of the risk and
liability away too when you don't have
to cover the loan on top of making sure
that you're I mean this is a part-time
job you signed up for to just do all of
this subcontracting yourself versus
having a general contractor who's
basically the middleman handling this
whole project for you and so that's why
it's more expensive is they're taking on
the headache instead of you having to
you know hassle all these guys make sure
they show up make sure the work is being
done correctly and so that's kind of on
you and that's the scarier part and
there's less liabilities that way
because the general contractor has their
own insurance and you don't yep yeah Joe
what kind of income do you and your wife
make
um we do pretty well uh um north of 300
Grand okay so let me let me just re let
me just run through this really quick so
you make north of 300 Grand you've got
200 Grand cash in the bank is that right
yep and you're thinking about building a
500 000 house roughly yeah yep yep
um
I mean I'm not anti-what George is
saying because you guys have the income
too available to cash flow this build I
mean you guys could go rent a small
apartment or whatever I don't know if
you got kids I guess I shouldn't say a
small apartment when I don't know what
your family situation is but the point
is yeah so I mean you could you can cash
flow this build that's absolutely right
with 200 Grand down to get that started
and get a quality GC I just I appreciate
your efforts to save money and seeing
the sticker shock of a GC but I'm going
to tell you something I my father-in-law
is a is a general contractor custom home
builder and I'm just going to tell you
it's there's one thing between getting
ripped off and another thing to pay a
premium for something that should be a
premium product and your home is a
premium product you know I told George
one time don't buy cheap shoes buy nice
leather shoes George he listened to me
all right you gotta you got to put the
money into the house and the good
general contractor it's not worth a
headache and the potential risk and all
kinds of nightmarish and I mean
nightmarish possibilities yeah unless
you come from that world and you know it
inside and out and you feel comfortable
handling it then I I wouldn't personally
become the general contractor in this
scenario and with your income it is
worth the premium you're going to pay to
have that headache off of your shoulder
and this is the long-term play right Joe
this is the house like you bought this
so I mean dude I'd be patient so you've
got 200 to put down that's almost 50
percent you know so you know I I I'm
with George on his option or just go
ahead and let's see what the financing
looks like if we actually had a GC
and Dave would tell you he built this
building and this campus at the speed of
cash and if we didn't have the cash on
hand well it's going to take longer to
build and so part of it is just
understanding it's going to be a process
it's going to take a lot of patience we
have to have a game plan for how this is
going to be sustainable for the next
year or two as we complete this build
but man you're going to get on the other
side of it with no headaches and no
payments and I love that part of it
yeah you're not kidding yeah well thank
you Joe appreciate the call yeah thank
you yeah yeah no no gcn For You Joe
right let's go get somebody that's a pro
you know there's something to be said
there you start thinking about you know
okay and but boy I've never even heard
of the private loan from the business
yeah the non-traditional financing side
yikes that worried me what's what's in
that fine print I don't wanna uncover
that you cover that the fine print
podcast oh and that might be a future
episode Ken you know like the the the
the the what would you even call that
you don't even call that non-traditional
financing he threw out a name I didn't
hear it uh clearly but yeah that makes
me really really nice if a bank is like
this is too much risk for us I go who's
covering that who's willing to take on
that that's a very good point when a
banker won't touch it you should
probably walk slowly away and they got
plenty of money and they say no thanks
Tom Hanks yeah and uh they're what are
you you you turned into an 80 year old
guy you can't say that ever again I'm a
no you're not we're just two old guys
like the guys on Sesame Street up in the
balcony that could be us but you're not
there yet now George here's why the
contractor matters right you got to make
sure that you talk to several
contractors this is like you know we
tell people look for our smartvester
Pros shopping and women that we've
already vetted yeah we still say go sit
with them and interview them and make
sure that you feel good about them and
on a general contract I just want to
point this out there is no reason to
rush into building a home it is just too
too important it's a wild time right now
too just trying to find people who are
willing to do the work I talk to many
people in my area you know that uh new
good General Contractors who's building
homes we want to do a custom build
sounds like it's a custom build you know
who do you work with and uh and you got
to interview them just like you would
someone who's going to be an in-home
Nanny like you this is a high trust
relationship we did a build on our first
town home it was a new construction
build through a builder and it was a
part-time to full-time job just keeping
track going up they the towel bars in
the wrong spot spot why'd they mess that
up we gotta fight them on this and so
it's a lot of work when you step into
something like that you got to be ready
I feel like Stacy said that once when I
probably put up the towel bar that's in
the wrong spot Ken I should never do any
help you're in the wrong line of
business yeah uh I'll tell you what
folks it's been a fun hour that way it's
fast I want to thank George Campbell I
want to thank the crew behind the glass
to keep us on the air I want to thank
you America you are the reason we do the
show this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where we talk about your
life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George Campbell we're here for you this
hour it's a free phone call if you want
to jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five George
is going to take care of the specific
money questions I'll chime in and I'm
here to answer any of your work
questions uh relating to hey do I take
this promotion uh do I change Fields can
I work a side hustle should I work a
side hustle uh any of those related
issues as relates to your income I'm
here to help you make more income and
more impact and we'll work together to
help you phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Ariel
is in San Diego California Ariel how can
we help
hi thanks for having me
um so I know the math Works in
California but I'm single I make about
90 000 a year between my full-time and
my side hustle and I'm just feeling like
it's impossible to save enough to where
I can afford a 25 of my income mortgage
um and I'm just wondering at what point
do you just give up on home ownership
and just decide to rent wow it got dark
real quick Ariel you just were like ah
it's over how old are you
I'm 44. okay so you've got plenty of
time and you do live in a high cost of
living area you make 90 000 where's all
your money currently going do you have
any debt
no I'm on set 3D okay so how much do you
have saved currently
um we've got about 13 000. all right
that's a great start so what makes you
think I'll never have a hundred I'll
never have 150.
well in order to afford that 25 percent
you guys recommend I would need a 260
000 down payment on what kind of house
that would be a one bedroom condo four
hundred thousand is the
one bedroom condo here okay
and do you can you live further out than
that do you have to live in in the
proper San Diego proper
go a little farther out would be about
380. if I go like half hour out from
where I'm at right now
okay yeah and so how quickly if you're
making 90 you think your income will go
up over the next decade
I think so yeah
yeah okay I don't want to work two jobs
for a decade you know right so what
could your professional uh income look
like what would that look like if you
really walked up the ladder that maybe
you're on or you'd like to be on what
what do you think you could make
um well there's a potential for me to
get a promotion within the next year and
but it would only vote me up by ten
thousand
um
so that would definitely help though
um and then as far as moving up in my
career I'm I'm trying to expand like
what what to look at and so I have
started looking into being like a safety
manager but there's just a lot of
schooling that goes into that so then my
savings would go to cash flowing and
these all these certifications I would
need so I don't know I'm just right at
the beginning of potentially looking for
a different job because I really love my
job well just Ballpark and I don't want
to get us lost in this but it'll be the
last question I ask on this but what do
you think those certifications would
cost you roughly all of them
um
10 to 15 000.
and then that would give you the
opportunity to make how much more in
income
so
my full-time job I currently make 72 and
that job the top end is 93.
okay all right so Ariel here's how
here's how I look at it with renting the
cost of living is only going to continue
to increase and so rent is going to
continue to go up over the next decade
in San Diego would you agree yes and so
while it may take longer for you to get
into that condo or house I also don't
want you to give up and just go well I'm
just going to rent until I retire and
pass away I don't want that to be the
the mo either and so I think we can find
some in between and when it comes to our
25 parameter on that 15-year fixed that
is your income after taxes but before
other deductions like your health care
your 401k so is that how you've been
calculating this
no I was going according to what money
hits my bank account okay well that can
be a slightly confusing number because
of that the parameters are really
because deductions can differ and so if
you're investing 15 well it's still a
quarter of your your income but because
of those deductions and because you live
in a high-tech State you're not seeing a
whole bunch of your paycheck right
correct so if that number did change you
could probably get in that house a few
years sooner correct yeah and so if you
do the math on that go back to the
mortgage calculator it might mean you
need to put 200 down on a four hundred
thousand dollar house and if we can
create enough margin to go all right I
can put you know five four grand away
every month for 12 months that's 48 000
a year and after four years I've got
what I need while I've been investing 15
and if that means we have to go get more
income it's worth doing
yeah so what are you doing for work you
said
um I manage a public swimming pool okay
I work for the city so are there other
management jobs maybe in the private
sector that could pay you more than that
absolutely the answer is yes sorry I
jumped in Ariel he got excited well yeah
because he
did and we with a municipality or state
government job you just are and the fact
is you've got skills and experience that
are very transferable and and I and
again I think what George said is
absolutely the way to go but I also
think that your income potential is far
bigger than you realize and it work it
makes a lot of sense for you to at least
look around and go all right what could
that look like
because if I'm in again I'm not gonna
just you know pigeonhole you but the 15
000 in inserts that you talked about
being able to make you 30 or 40 more a
year well that pays off pretty quickly
uh but I think it could be much higher
than that um and you know what I'm gonna
do George we got a brand new bundle I'm
gonna give away to Ariel how about that
I love this so Ariel here's what I want
you to do uh I want you to hang on the
line and we're going to give you the
increase your income bundle it's at
ramseysolutions.com in the store and
it's got my book from paycheck to
purpose which will give you the seven
stages to finding and doing work that
you love and you get paid well to do the
get clear assessment which will help you
out with ideas the get hired digital
course where I teach you how to do
everything that's actually in the book
and then we have resume templates that
are very very popular that'll help you
stand out so I'm going to bundle all
that for you it's called the increase
your income bundle Jordan love that and
it's got all kinds of you get the book
you get the digital tool you get the
assessment you have the templates the
course the course yeah
you know how to get hired a signed photo
of you that's the eight by ten glossy of
George Campbell's not included in the
increase your income bundle so hang on
the line uh and we'll get you that and
that George really is the key yeah to
the Gap well with a high cost of living
area especially making 70.
I'll never do it no I'm gonna go make
more money and now's a great time to do
that so I love it yeah appreciate the
call Ariel you'll get there I love San
Diego George you know a wonderful area
no bugs
didn't think about that that was not on
my list of why I love San Diego well I
like to sit outside on a nice summer
evening in uh in Tennessee you're going
to be swatting some mosquitoes no thanks
or as they say in the Deep South
Skeeters Skeeters there you go teaching
something new every day to you George
hey don't move
[Music]
more valuable information than that
because the Rams are shooting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
he is George Campbell thrilled that you
have joined us today the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more all you got to do is use
the promo code Ramsay to get the best
deal
today's question comes from William in
New Mexico
are there new rules for buying used
versus new and Lease first financing in
this post-covet era my family has been
looking for a used car we can pay cash
for like we were taught in Financial
Peace University and we're finding used
cars only a few thousand dollars less
than new we also learned the insurance
companies are asking for additional
Bridge coverage since the used cars are
not as valuable as they're being sold
for ugh help please yeah there you go
George okay so we're right down your
lane well there's a there's a lot going
on here that grinds my gears Ken going
boy not to have a car analogy I like
what you did there but this idea that
well used cars are only going for a few
thousand dollars less than new yeah if
you're looking at thirty eight thousand
dollar used cars thank you very much
most people don't need to be driving
that uh based on the average income
people need to be looking for fifteen
thousand dollar cars and let me tell you
there's not five thousand new cars but
some people need to even be looking at
five to seven thousand dollar cards
stores depending on their situation and
one of our favorite things to do
give me something while you're teaching
I'm going to pull up a sample okay well
you know a car that we recommend here
frequently is a Honda so let's look up a
Honda Civic all right used let's just
see in the end all right you keep on
teaching I'm going to do your homework
so no there are no new rules for buying
used versus new and least for we Our
advice still stays the same stay away
from debt at all costs and save up and
pay cash for a reliable used car no we
don't mean take a briefcase full of
dollar bills to the dealership that's
not gonna work uh but you can take a
money order or a cashier's cashier's
check
and go and do that now a lot of
dealerships make their money through
financing the margin on cars can be as
low as six percent the margin on
financing can be as high as 60 percent
and so when you walk in there and you
tell them hey I'd like to pay cash a lot
of the times they're gonna sometimes
they'll say we're not gonna sell it to
you at that price because they don't
make enough money on the deal they'll
wait for the next guy to walk in who's
ready to finance and so you've got to
know exactly what you're walking into
and this means doing all your research
ahead of time online knowing the value
of the car you're going to buy and you
can tell them you can wait till the end
and say what's the out the door price
that's what you're looking for is the
out the door price because that includes
all of the fees and when you look at
those fees make sure you don't pay
anything more than sales tax and a small
doc fee anything else is highway robbery
they go oh that's a mandatory warrant no
I'm not paying that and watch what
happens when you walk out the door
they'll be chasing you within three
minutes because they see a guy with a
check in hand ready to buy all right so
what do you got for me Ken all right
thank you George this is my favorite
things to do so Ken here's the the
people objection is Ken there's no cars
under fifteen thousand dollars I gotta
go buy a 38 000 used car and I would say
that is not true and I've got the
results right here George I just got a
quick search uh using AutoTrader in the
Franklin Tennessee area okay all right
I'm gonna give you some options here
okay first we've got a used 2008 Honda
Civic EX uh 129 000 miles which for a
Honda is barely getting started the car
hasn't even woken up yet the cars
thank you very much seven thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars wow okay uh
by the way it's a nice little blue paint
job it looks fine all right let's go up
a little bit all right uh we've got a uh
what about in the 10 000 range Ken what
can we get there's no need to shout
George sorry I'm getting excited uh here
we go we have a used 2008 Honda Civic
it's an EXL that's top of the line it's
an e see you know EXL I owned one you
did yeah 145 000 miles again for a Honda
not a big deal
999 so that's just below the uh the
threshold is it gonna impress anyone no
no we'll get you from A to B with very
little repairs and maintenance costs yes
yeah yeah oh sorry yeah yeah yeah so
again that's just one example uh I get
very excited about this because I'm in
the market right now for a teenager and
I'm looking at this stuff all the time
by the way I should point out Facebook
Marketplace great place to find good
deals and you can negotiate over there
yes you're dealing with a private seller
and and uh you show up with cash
Dave Ramsey taught me that many years
ago I mean literally show up and go this
is what I'm paying right now and you
count it out lay it on the hood of the
car and do it somewhere public by the
way if you're gonna do that yeah don't
put yourself in a precarious situation
bring it bring a friend with you by the
way grocery store parking lots great
place to do that Banks uh police you
know you can go to all these places yeah
that's great meet me at the police
station police station is one of the
deals happen my friend oh wow you really
are scared young you were really scared
well anyways I don't know what it's like
in New Mexico I can't imagine it's much
much different it's not so yes if you
want to buy an insane used car yeah it
might be a few thousand left oh look at
this George I Gotta Throw one more in
here use 2015 Honda Civic 106 000 miles
they're asking eleven nine there you go
so don't tell me it can't be done so it
can be done absolutely and we don't tell
people to go out and buy a new car until
they have a net worth of a million
dollars or more and that's for one
simple reason it's just too much of your
world to spend that kind of money on a
depreciating asset yeah so there you go
William hope that helps good stuff
thanks for the question all right let's
go to Buffalo New York Steve is on the
line Steve how can we help
hi how you doing guys good
so this is my first time asking for help
or calling you guys hey Steve could you
uh adjust your phone a little bit you
feel like you uh are muffled
is that better not much do you don't
have a sock over the phone do you
not at all all right well let's try that
go ahead
okay so I had it's my first time calling
you guys and that's it for help okay um
I just learned about you guys not too
long ago about two months
um last year a little bit more than last
year somewhere around June
I had 232
000 110. wow
um I bought a new truck my old one died
I do a lot of Towing
pay for cash
paid that off
I bought a house had refinanced
um
hell had a problem with my house it was
like The Money Pit
I had about 10 grand in credit card debt
I'm down to about 135
000.
and now I'm stuck where I
not really paying
um
every little Penny I have to pay off the
vet faster I'm kind of like stuck trying
to figure out how to get back on track
does that include your mortgage
um yeah that's including my mortgage
okay let's parse that out how much of
the Consumer Debt aside from the
mortgage what does that add up to
any consumer that like credit card debt
everything but the house what is that
debt add up to
oh uh oh
about 12 000. okay and the rest is the
mortgage
yeah okay so now it's a different
conversation so now the question becomes
how can we pay off twelve thousand
dollars very quickly
so what's your income
uh I think about 80 to 90 000 a year so
making ninety thousand a year how
quickly can you pay off twelve thousand
if you pay off the smallest loan first
and start attacking that one with a
vengeance
and so you just said you were feeling
stuck and we just showed you a path out
within a few months and now all you have
left is the mortgage which goes into
what we call baby step six so you said
you're a new listener let me lay it out
for you real quick
baby step one thousand dollar emergency
fund you have that right you've got a
thousand bucks in the bank yeah anything
beyond that we can throw towards the
debt how much cash do you have in the
bank
about five grand okay so we can take
four of that onto the twelve now we're
down to eight
and now we start listing out the debts
smallest to largest what's your smallest
debt you have right now based on the
balance ignoring the interest rate
I have no interest rates that's zero
percent for uh one year I arrived a year
to pay Paul okay so what's the lowest
balance
um
like
13 1390 is the lowest balance I mean I
can see that so you knock that out with
the 4000 you have in the bank and now
you're on your way and so continue that
in a few months you're completely debt
free then save up your fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses we're gonna help you out with
this by gifting you one year of
Financial Peace University watch the
first few lessons get fired up continue
to watch them and that will help us walk
you through this wild journey of the
Ramsay baby steps that's helped 10
million people get out of debt and build
wealth and you're next Steve Steve you
got this man you're doing much better
than you're not stuck yeah you're in
great shape thank you so much for the
call more Ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman and I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell we're talking about your
life specifically your money your work
your relationships uh how many of you
are in a stuck situation in your
professional life I I'm here today to
help with that and you'd be surprised at
how that might help you in your money
life as well any work related questions
let's take some of those today and of
course we're gonna take your money
questions George is all fired up I'm
starting to feel bad George nobody
nobody's asking me any specific
questions well Ken the truth is as I
talk to people and do the entree
leadership podcast you know is it stats
still 68 of workers are disengaged I
know they don't want to be there they
don't want to be there they don't like
their co-workers they don't like their
boss they don't even enjoy the work that
I'm doing and you're going it doesn't
have to be this way guys yeah and also
you feel undervalued and underpaid
that's overworked and they don't see
Away George tell folks what happens when
you when you use what you do best to do
work you love to produce results that
matter to you that's a great question
what happens well you light up like a
Christmas tree More Money More meaning
more impact more income boom so I'm here
to help out with those questions today
but first Emily is up in Denver Colorado
the mile high city George I like to
learn something new I like to give you a
little nugget Emily how can we help
thanks for taking my call you bet how
can we help today Emily
hi I'm trying to get prepared for
college savings I have a three-year-old
and a kid on the way
and uh my husband and I both went to
their expensive schools and kind of
looking at the six percent growth and
tuition year over year the total amount
to save is very high
and I'm curious if you know I'd loved
for my kids to have scholarships and
everything but I want to be prepared for
worst case scenario
and I'm curious if there's any scenario
where you'd recommend putting some of
that Savings in something other than a
529
hmm what do you mean by other than where
else would you put it are you
considering
scholarship then I won't need hopefully
all that money and I'm curious if
there's any benefit or recommendations
for not getting that 10 percent
well even if you get a scholarship
what's really cool about these plans is
you can withdraw against that
scholarship so if let's say there's a
twenty thousand dollar scholarship and
you go well now I didn't need this money
well you can withdraw 20 000 from that
savings account tax-free
okay so that doesn't need to be a
concern and there's broad application
into how you can use those funds when we
talk about learning and education it's
very room and board the laptops the
books are so much regardless of where
there's trade schools
certifications you know talk about
online you know technology programs like
Bethel Tech which I endorse I mean
listen they can go a lot of different
ways it's not like you're trapped is
that what you're feeling okay
I'm just it seems like a lot of money to
sit and it's like 29 so I wasn't sure if
it well how much money are you talking
about something
well like where I went to school if I
was projecting that for my daughter it'd
be just shy of 800k when she's what okay
holy oh yeah that's crazy I'm a little
short of breath why does she need to go
there 800 why does anyone need to go
there where is she going
it's just it's like a top tier school I
I mean I don't know if she will but I
would love to be able to provide please
okay how much did you pay for it because
I'm now I'm very curious yeah
well I had need-based scholarships but
the full rate when I went to school was
about 40K a year okay that sounds a lot
more reasonable compared to 800k for
four years
yeah and they today's rate is like 80k
okay can I ask you a question can I ask
you a question I really and I'm okay if
it's different than what I think but I'm
curious to know you said you and your
husband both went to very expensive
schools
okay
do you think that those schools were
worth the tuition based on where you
guys are now
and maybe where you could have gone to
school
I believe so and your husband
got a full he he did Roxy so he did he
did he got a full scholarship so he
didn't end up paying but
um I believe it was worth it if if my
daughter wanted to go but you didn't I
mean this sounds like neither one of you
paid full tuition or anything close
correct correct yeah I gotta tell you I
I I just want to challenge you on name
brand schools
um let me put it this way
uh you remember the last time you went
to the doctor I mean you're getting
ready to have a baby so remember your
last checkup
yeah yeah at any point in your medical
Journey when you were getting baby
checkups or your own personal health
have you ever asked your doctor to uh
bring their diploma in and show you
their diploma
why
uh I don't know
yeah so how in the world would you trust
the life of your baby with this Doctor
Who you don't even know where he went to
med school in undergrad
right all right you get where I'm going
here
I'm not anti-education Emily but I'm
telling you nobody cares
nobody cares where you went to school
uh education important for the
qualification you need yes notice I said
for the qualification yet you need and
your kids the landscape of education is
changing so rapidly that by the time
your kids are there the 529 is the
safest play just give you an idea right
now okay so enrollment is down
tremendously
ten percent I mean uh uh I just put this
out there I gotta look it up uh but
enrollment is down so much right now in
the United States and it's gen Z so this
is the generation right now that's in
high school and they're looking at this
stuff and just to give you the numbers
College Roman is down nearly 10 over the
last two years only 51 percent of gen Z
teens are considering a four-year degree
that's a 20-point drop since May of
2020. the point is there's a lot of
Education options that aren't going to
look like they look right now
and so I think the 529 George the point
I'm making is whether I'm right or wrong
and what I predict it gives her
flexibility oh yeah and one other thing
Emily if you put that money elsewhere it
is going to have a tax burden on it and
so if you put it in the 529 it goes in
tax-free grows tax-free you can withdraw
it tax-free you can also change the
beneficiary and it's very loose this
could be spouse this could be in-laws it
could be children including step
children foster children siblings step
siblings nieces nephews Aunts Uncles
first cousins so the options are endless
this money is not going to go to waste
and I assume you guys have an amazing
household income can you tell me what it
is
I think it's around 500k there we go
okay so here's the thing by the time
they're 16 17 they start applying to
colleges yeah you guys could could cash
flow this as well yeah right very easily
maybe yeah I I don't know by the time
they're going to college you're going to
be completely dead free including the
house right if you're not already right
and so at that point making 500 000 this
is a rhetorical question by the way
could you cash flow College the entire
audience listening is screaming yes
trust me you can
great you couldn't cash flow 80k a year
making 500 000.
oh no I could yeah definitely there we
go okay so I still would do the 529.
that will look like because
strategically it's a smart move to
invest with that kind of tax advantage
and you can always change the
beneficiary you can withdraw against the
scholarship there's so many options
there and then a worst case scenario
when you can withdraw it it's going to
create you know income tax and there's a
10 penalty but that is a worse worse
worst case scenario and there's a lot of
things you can do with that money yeah
and then there's the fact that your kid
may show up one day at 16 17 and go hey
I want to do this I know I want to do
this and this is how I can go do this
and it has nothing to do with a
four-year degree and the fancy college
that you went to that you'd like your
kid to go to parents we got to wake up
and sometimes those fancy colleges are
more about our desires than they're just
whoa there it is Ken
well it is
okay now I'm fired up here's one more
for you college degrees have become more
about status than actual success and
that's the reality and uh the landscape
is changing so I say all that to say
investing in a 529 for Relevant
education
is the way to go George you laid it up
right beautifully preach it and my
goodness everybody but the household dog
is uh it's amazing Fido might be on
there who knows yeah we'll dig into that
on the commercial all right college is
the future oh boy I'm gonna get George's
meds for the rest of you hang on we'll
be right back this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win
in your life in your money life your
work life your relationship life I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell who is
uh as I've said uh
uh twice choose your words carefully Ken
huh choose your words carefully I didn't
know what was I was trying to remember
how many times I've said it but again if
you're watching the show on YouTube
George is uh in the fall spirit I dress
to impress Mr Coleman uh hey we're fired
up we're getting ready to head to Dallas
this weekend you got your uh your outfit
your stage outfit plan
backpacked I have not thought about it
you thought I'd uh we'd make sure we
coordinate okay coordinator outfits oh
no I don't think we should ever do that
that would be a disaster
our smart conference is uh one of the
biggest Ramsey events we do we're gonna
have six thousand plus people in an
arena in Dallas Texas since we've done
something like that it really has that
thing uh the kovitz uh kept us away and
uh so we're very excited to be back back
to Arena it's gonna be fun uh we're
gonna be talking about all of the topics
we talk about here on the Ramsey Show
Money uh life marriage relationships
work
uh it's so much more Dave Ramsey Rachel
Cruz uh myself John deloney Christina
Ellis and of course George Campbell uh
and our special guest Craig and Amy
grossel are going to be joining us and
uh it's an awesome day uh it is the
Smart conference this Saturday October
22nd go to Ramsay solutions.com events
that's ramseysolutions.com get your
tickets now gonna be fun George I think
you should wear a cowboy hat I you know
years ago confirmed or denied that I
purchased one oh is that right last
night for the event for the event now
this is making me very happy you will
remember uh years ago I was the emcee of
all Rams events and when we first went
to Dallas I uh didn't steal that's it's
aggressive I asked a gentleman who was
sitting on the second row
if I could wear his Stetson on the stage
and he let me do it and it was a great
idea until I put it on my head it was a
little sweaty a little sweaty and a
little big wow and so it was it just
looked silly on me it was like down on
the top of the ears and I look like I
had my dad's cowboy hat No One Believes
it the crowd loved it though huh No One
Believes us wearing a cowboy hat I've
got a nice one now the one that actually
fits my head but uh I don't wear it very
often for good reason some guys can pull
off a Stetson you know I don't hide it
under a bushel that's how I feel about
the haircut you work too hard on that
though oh man but it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be fun make the drive if you're
even near Dallas people fly from all
over the country to join us for this so
just because you're not in Dallas
doesn't mean you're not invited that's
right gonna be a fun day love to see you
there Abraham is up in doubt oh speaking
of Dallas Texas Abraham is there how can
we help
hey there so I'm gonna lay out my
situation I graduated this year and I go
on a mission trip next year starting in
July that'll be nine months so I'm
basically framing my economic situation
around that uh I own well I have
purchased an RV from my grandparents
that they were that they were selling
that uh eight thousand dollars I have 6
300 left on that but I do not have a car
I have a full-time job and I'm using
family vehicles to transit to and from
that my question is should I pay off uh
that I need to pay off the RV by the
time I leave uh should I pay that off
aggressive will I throw everything
except my emergency fund at the RV
treated as a Consumer Debt there's no
interest on it uh but I do want to get
rid of the debt as fast as possible or
should I continue paying 700 a month
that I am to be on track to pay it off
by the end of by June
and uh and by like just say for a car uh
immediately are you living in the RV
yes sir so this is your home so we can't
we're not going to do anything else with
it and how much do you have in the bank
uh sixteen hundred dollars okay
well there's not a ton you can throw at
it obviously I would tell you to throw
600 of the 16 at it uh to to kick start
it by an extra month how much faster
you're going to do that while saving for
a car because it sounds like you need to
split the difference
yeah what I mean is I just recently got
a job so I'm 1500 take-home pays what
I'm going to have what I mean is like
should I throw that 1500 at it after
expenses is what I mean
but you still have no vehicle
you're correct so I think we need to get
you maybe we take the the next three
months of income get you a vehicle and
then get aggressive paying on this RV
loan that you owe to Grandma and Grandpa
okay is it a personal loan or do you
take out a loan to purchase it
no sir it's uh it's basically just it's
an understanding that I owe them that
money and I'm paying it I'm being
consistent on that okay well it seems
like A1 is you need a vehicle to get
around in
so knowing you're not going to need it
for very long I would get as cheap of a
vehicle as you can that is reliable
that's not going to have five thousand
dollars in repairs in the next six
months
how long are you planning to live in the
RV
uh feasibly I could live in it until
probably I get married
I think
um just as I as I suck away money for a
down payment on a how old are you
I'm 19. okay yeah it's a young man's
game Ken he can do it oh 100 there's no
question about are you are you are you
where are you parking the RV
uh it's on my family's property in the
back corner oh we have a fairly sizable
property okay gotcha so you're all set
there so how much how much can you save
each month for this car if you put
everything towards that goal
uh I could save probably 1300 for the
car oh awesome I do have a couple of
insurance payments so let's say that's
three months you have Thirty thirty nine
hundred dollars
could that get you a beater car in your
area maybe on Facebook Marketplace or
something or someone you know getting
rid of an old car
for sure probably four months would be
even better okay and then after four
months you have a car now you can put
all of that margin towards the RV and
you're gonna have that paid off by the
time you leave for the mission trip
yeah okay I like this plan
okay
the the question is can you find the
reliable car under four grand and it
sounds like you're willing to do it
uh reliable I mean you you need to make
something pretty it may not I know I
paid six grand for my Honda
and it you know had a little bit of body
damage but mechanically it was very
sound so just find the ugliest thing you
can find that is mechanically sound
that's the key to finding a deal I mean
you got a 19 year old you got a lot more
options you know than just that I mean
it's like uh we didn't ask but can he
bike Kenny bicycle I mean it depends on
how intense you want to be I understand
it can get cold in the Dallas area I
don't know where he's going it could be
a far distance in Dallas I know I know
you know he could get a horse no boy you
know how I feel about horses Ken
it may be a great mode of transportation
oh George that's terrible Hannah is up
in Austin Texas Hannah how can we help
hey y'all thanks for taking
because I have a car I don't owe
anything on it and it has about a year
left
um
oh I can tell is that a feature I love
her response uh George I I've already
thought about this response I know so
you know this car is gonna die one year
from today
approximately
I love it okay okay we don't have time
to break that down
I have a good bit of savings
um
I do have a difficult time parting with
it though I'm just wondering should I
continue to save up until my car
completely gives out on me or should I
just bite the bullet spend the money on
the car now well it depends you're gonna
have to make a bunch of repairs on it in
the next 12 months
are
is worth about 2 000 I need to do around
600 worth of root beers and then you
could sell it for 2600 or more at that
point
yeah okay if you'll recoup the costs on
it may be worth it how much money do you
have saved
about 25 000. oh awesome what's your
income
uh 90 grand wonderful uh yeah yeah that
sounds very reasonable I mean why don't
you just go ahead and get the car now
she doesn't want to part with the
savings yeah the part with the savings
are part with the car is it a
Sentimental thing I don't want to park
with the um savings I grew up with a lot
of Financial and security so okay so do
you have an emergency fund
yeah 12 12 months you're 12 months of
emergency savings
wow what if you eased into it maybe got
a really nice ten thousand dollar car
and just kind of like eased into this
process because it's this is a big
emotional thing George well yeah you've
when you have that kind of background
there's some Financial trauma here yeah
you have 12 months of savings you're
safe but your body is saying we're not
safe we're not safe and so I might
honestly look into some counseling to
help on that side but financially this
is a very wise move you've done the work
yeah don't wait till the eyes go ahead
and sell it as is
get a new car George good stuff this
hour I want to thank the team uh for
keeping us on the air and you America
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsey Show it's where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about life money work relationships and
more the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm Ken
Coleman co-hosting with me today George
camel it's uh Coleman and camel the law
firm you should never don't hire us for
law advice yeah not at all but we can
give you advice it's free so it is worth
uh what you pay for keep that in mind
but we're here to help out uh
specifically in areas of money and work
life issues as well triple eight eight
two five five two two five Alberta
Canada is where we go next Maggie is
there mag how can we help
oh hi
um really awesome to talk to you guys I
feel like I'm talking to celebrities
this is really cool wow you need to get
out more Maggie yeah I gotta tell you
you set your sights a little higher if
we're celebrities but thank you for the
nice work we're excited to talk to you
nice okay
um so I guess with my question is so I'm
a single mom and I work full-time and
I'm just wondering how I can increase
and actually start making income from my
side hustle okay what is your side
Hustle
um I make reusable baby wipes from
upcycled Material interesting now I
gotta tell you I am absolutely locked in
now how does this how does one do this
and explain what that means upcycled
like explain the whole deal
yeah so I just um I
I a thrift store and I get essentially
like old sheets that people have donated
obviously not like super damaged ones
um and I use that material instead of
using new
um and then I essentially sew them
together in a nice way that people can
use uh to use
um for a baby like specifically like
baby bum wipes because I use them and
obviously being a single parent I saved
a lot of money that way
um so you take old you take used bed
sheets
yeah cut them up sew them into uh baby
bum size wipes and you and it's like a
cloth wipe but it's a sheet and then you
wash them and reuse them
yeah yeah okay wow wow well what has
this business done so far
um it hasn't yet that's the thing so I
I'm really good at making them
um but everything else I get really
overwhelmed
um
we need to make sure there's a market
needed do people asking for do you tell
your girlfriends to have babies about
this concept and do you do you let them
borrow some if that's a thing
um I definitely have gave some away I
guess a part of me like
maybe feel assistant I'm just like oh my
God like they're gonna think I'm a
weirdo for
for being so obsessed with my own idea
like if that makes any sense it is a
really Niche thing right it's extremely
neat yeah I've heard of the reusable
diapers and I imagine it's something
similar to that well George doesn't know
what this is like but back in my day
yeah we had cloth diapers you know so I
get it it just falls into that category
right Maggie yes
yes yeah but the reason that people
moved on from cloth diapers is the
reason why I think you got a challenge
with this product and I don't want to
you know part in the Shark Tank here I
don't want to poo-poo your idea no pun
intended no I actually intended that pun
actually I had to it was just right
there but but but here's the thing uh
the reason we moved on from that is
because of the uh just the sheer amount
of time that's saved you know with the
baby wipes and and then we throw them
away and and then we move on and I don't
want to again Rob you of your joy on
this but you've got to determine if
there's an actual market for this and we
start small and it is overwhelming for
anybody to have an idea no matter what
it is
and then try to get that idea out there
but the way you start is testing in real
life okay so or any of my girlfriends
interested in this like you literally
need to go hey I need you to shoot me
straight
you're not gonna hurt my feelings
but if if I made these for you and let
you test them out will you test them out
and tell me whether or not you would do
this you got to get some real feedback
on the idea here because this could be
so Niche that nobody in the world wants
to do it and so then we go okay I love
the idea for me
it's a novelty it's something I'm going
to do but as it relates to being a
single mom and making money I've got to
do something where I'm using my skill
and experience and I'm transferring
value that's what you've got to do here
so I think it's a long shot on this I
wanna I don't want to be unkind but I
think this is just a long long long shot
and I wouldn't
put much more time into it other than it
takes to really truly test it locally
okay do you understand what I'm saying I
don't I don't want to deflate you but
I'm just telling you if you're using
this as a passion project I think it's
great if you're trying to pay off debt
and you've got financial goals ahead of
you yeah I think you should find
something you can do today that will
bring in money today guaranteed and you
can still work on this and have it be a
passion project and there are ways you
can try to test this idea maybe join
some of these a kind of crunchy mom
Facebook groups people that really want
to lean into natural products what does
crunchy mean that means they're very
they want to go all natural they don't
want to use you know traditional
medication they want to use essential
oils and more natural I think that's the
target demo Maggie I would assume right
of people who would be interested in
this
yeah absolutely yeah yeah I definitely
want you to test it but test it locally
to George's point maybe in some uh some
online communities put your product up
there show them how you do it uh see if
you can get a blog post out there you
just got to see if there's any appetite
for this product
okay yeah that makes sense I guess I'm
just like stressed too because I'm on
baby step two and it's like I'm a single
mom so working
you know I if I could work 24 hours a
day I definitely would be right now
because that's how determined I feel but
having a little one it's just like I
need something I can do from home at
least okay and I thought all right now
that so here's the deal let me help you
right there because I I want you to test
this out and keep this thing alive until
there's no evidence that says there's a
market for this maybe there is a market
for it but right now we need to put that
on the back burner and what you need to
be doing is okay how many hours a week
do you have to be able to work and what
can you do remotely and remote work is
as popular as it's ever been on this
planet
and you just need to look at what skills
you have what experience you have make a
list and you go okay I'm going to apply
for these type of jobs maybe it's a
customer service job or you're on the
phone x amount of hours a day helping
people it's not fun it's not great but
it allows you to get out of debt and be
at home near the baby do you understand
what our focus is
yeah absolutely yeah you look you just
do what you can do right now
okay because of the baby and because of
the debt and everything you got going on
we are focused on high priority stuff
all right and then you could test the
the the the baby wipe thing on the side
while you're doing that not put any
pressure on yourself that needs to be a
labor of love something that you want to
see if it works but no pressure on it
and that'll take away that feeling
George of being overwhelmed because
listen any entrepreneur no matter what
the product or service is just to think
of the finished product and how do I get
it out there but it's Gonna Take Years
to paralyze you uh analysis paralysis is
what it's called and uh right now you
got to be focused on paying off debt
getting that emergency fund baby step
three is is next and then you're on your
way and that margin will free you up to
focus on the entrepreneurial Ventures it
will yeah I learned a lot I can't wait
to tell Stacy what I learned about
absolutely the new improved baby boy
time to be alive it is very exciting
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm joined by George Campbell we're here
for you this hour taking your phone
calls about money life work
relationships and and so forth I uh I'm
sorry I'm still I got a little chuckle
still we're lots of conversation from
our last segment so here we go I'm gonna
focus and we're going to Chris and
Bismarck North Dakota Chris how can we
help
hey can you hear me loud and clear sir
what's going on
hey yeah so I uh recently started my uh
construction business about six months
ago oh nice and business has been debt
free and me and my wife are almost set
free just our mortgage on our house so
since I started the business our budget
and kind of everything to keep that out
of debt was you know our budget and
everything kind of got thrown out the
window so now that we're a little bit
into it kind of have a pulse for our
income with the business
um trying to trying to figure out how we
should budget how much I should pay
myself from the business and how to kind
of make a formula for that
sure what uh can you give us an idea
what your cash flow situation is what
you're bringing in
so so far the business it seems you know
it's really up and down but it seems
like it's about an average of maybe uh
five to six grand profit okay a month
and that includes after paying you
or no no that's that's what I'm trying
to do all right that's what I thought
okay great so that's five or six grand
but we're not paying you yet all right
are you making any money anywhere else
any income
uh my wife has a couple part-time jobs
and so far that's just been going into
our uh emergency fund trying to build
that up a little bit further all right
Grace you're living off what your wife
makes and you got five to six or average
five to six K in profit from the
construction company is that all sitting
in a savings account
um yeah I mean I've been pulling out
what I need to to pay myself it's it's
in its own business account and I've
just been pulling as I need to to pay
our expenses okay that's where I'm
confused because I asked you if you if
of that profit you were paying yourself
and you said no but now you're saying
you've been pulling some out
yeah yeah I guess that's that's five
grand of what the company makes and
that's that's total so out of that five
grand ish I've just been able to just
just pull money as I need it okay do you
have any savings for the company
for the company yeah it's it's right
right close to 10 grand with accounts
payable okay all right so beyond your
overhead your expenses all of that how
much could you pull from the profits
I mean if I if I wanted to since the
business is debt free and once
everything's paid I could probably take
you know three to four grand a month so
let's say you start paying yourself a
salary of four grand a month that's 48
000 a year year one and then your goal
is to increase that every year as you
have more and more profit and you start
to get a handle on the overhead and
you're putting some of this in retained
earnings and savings for the business as
well from that profit yeah
that's what I'm trying to figure out
so you've got 10 000 in the company
savings account right now and so I'm
George I'm going to be a little enough I
think I'd be more conservative George
I'd kind of want to see him try to limit
himself if possible to maybe 2500 a
month let's say he keeps that average of
five thousand this is a rule of thumb I
want to get what your take is George
there's no hard and fast rule just
putting it out there but I just be
conservative right now if I were you
Chris in your shoes well especially in
construction because that equipment is
expensive right and so I'd want to build
up the company's retained earnings
that's what we call an entree leadership
we talk about savings for a company I'd
probably be paying myself half
um so let's let's say on a six thousand
dollar profit month maybe pay yourself
three and put three in retained earnings
account I wanna you know I'm gonna make
something personally so that I can build
up the safety gland in the in the
preparation for this construction
company which hopefully we get to a
point where you got six months of your
income in that account you see where I'm
going with this right yeah as you grow
up you know now once once it gets going
and you're spitting off more profit you
know I think that formula changes you
pay yourself more save a little less
and as it grows things might change as
you might you know hire a few team
members is that the goal for you
um you know that's kind of a possibility
probably not anytime soon but yeah the
biggest thing right now is just um you
know the business is is doing well
enough on its own or I feel like I can
try to pay myself consistently and then
budget from that you know or I think
you're right I think you're right you're
doing it the the right way have you read
the book entree leadership yet
no I haven't okay that'll be our gift to
you today uh you're already living out a
lot of the principles in that book this
is Dave Ramsey's number one best-selling
book how he built this place from a card
table in his living room to the Empire
it is today with 1100 team members and a
whole campus and you're doing it right
the biggest piece here is doing it all
debt free and you've done that yes and
you're moving at the speed of cash and
you're willing to pay yourself a small
amount right now as you grow this thing
and so I would make it a personal goal
to increase my salary every year and
when you're a business owner like that
there could be a lot more margin you
might have an amazing year and you pay
yourself a hundred grand yeah and you've
got the savings and you're you're doing
it the right way so we're going to send
you that book I think it'll help walk
you through that you can also listen to
the entree leadership podcast which I
hope where we're helping leaders and
business owners win every single day
yeah that's it love to hear that it's a
great show yeah and Chris you're doing
it the right way grow slow you know and
and be okay being small right small and
slow is the way to get this thing going
this Construction Company because it is
a it is a customer based business in the
sense of they start talking about you
hey Chris did a good job on this Chris
did and they start spreading the word
you're gonna have more work than you can
keep up with and then that puts you in a
really great place as George was saying
is you have to maybe go out and and do
some you know subcontracting and things
like that so you're off to a good start
really proud of you I love seeing a guy
start something like that and having 10
grand in savings no debt on the business
you don't see that a lot especially in
construction because it's very tempting
and you can make a reasonable case if
you're not anti-debt the way we are that
oh I gotta have this equation I had to
go get this 50 Grand uh tractor can to
get this thing started yeah exactly I
love how you talked about it feels like
you know a lot about tractors I know
just enough to be dangerous that's right
Kevin is up next in Boise Idaho Kevin
how can we help
thank you for taking my call guys I am
65 years old I turned 66 next month I
own my own business I'm planning on
continuing working I'm also planning on
taking my Social Security March of 2023
so I use part of my Social Security to
pay for long-term insurance as we are
already putting in 15 to 20 in the
retirement Roth higher or whatever uh
we're also 100 debt free thank you Dave
and staff and we have five to six months
already an emergency fund and what
should we do with the rest of the 55
earlier with the Social Security money I
mean
um after we start collecting it awesome
it just took a 30-day year you just took
a 30-day European Vacation paid in full
hey
that's pretty awesome so how much is a
long-term insurance going to cost you
I'm going to say probably five to six
hundred a month
okay
and have you shopped that with our with
our friends at Xander online
I have not but I'm going to okay make
sure you do your homework on that to
make sure you're getting the best right
and so you can jump onto
ramsaysolutions.com and do that but once
you have that number now it becomes part
of your monthly budget and you are still
running this business how much what's
your household income
um we made 42 000 last year and still
we're able to take months off and all
that so we're good you're living on a
lot less than you make that's fantastic
that's right what's in your nest egg
uh we have probably eight to ten months
of emergency fund but beyond that do you
have any uh investing any IRAs 401ks yes
what's in that I've done Ross I've got
Iris what's it out 80 000 in the 80 000.
okay
so the question is how are we going to
long-term plan for retirement and then
what is the best use of the money in the
different buckets and so are you working
with a financial advisor right now
yes I am okay I would sit down with them
and make a game plan not just for the
next year but hey what does the next 10
years look like when can I actually
retire and then how can I use that
Social Security best you know should I
use some of the tax advantage money
first to cover long-term care versus
using my Social Security I would start
with the social security for now but I'm
curious to see what a full plan would
look like as you map out all the
different buckets you have to utilize it
because you might live another 30 years
and so I don't want you to run out of
money either yeah absolutely but boy is
he in great shape and uh coming on the
area coming off the 30-day trip to
Europe George debt free yeah uh we
didn't get a postcard I haven't seen one
from Kevin did you see I will awake you
get one we'll have to just Google
pictures for now yeah
by the way we uh we just recently had
dinner uh the camels and the Coleman's
maybe we should do a European uh couples
trip I don't know yeah sure sure yeah
you seem very excited about that we'll
get the wives together on that one
uh we made a vacation together we do
love doing the Ramsey Show together
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
thrilled that you're with us I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel tonight's
big night George
it is so you have your Healthy popcorn
ready do you have your Orville
Redenbacher's movie theater butter I got
a box of it at home I got a box what are
we talking about well tonight is the big
viewing party where you're premiering
the very popular runaway hit borrowed
future we're launching it on YouTube
tonight at 7 pm Central 8 Eastern Bard
features our award-winning documentary
that uncovers the dark side of the
student loan industry it's an incredible
watch it's gripping make you sick to
your stomach make you angry but it is
good good to watch it watch it with your
kids watch it with your family uh it's
going to be awesome
uh and then after tonight you can view
bar and future on YouTube for free on
demand the film is still available on
Amazon Prime Apple TV Google Play and
ramseysolutions.com where you can rent
it
ad free so we want you to see this for
your own information but also to spread
the word help us
disrupt the toxic student loan industry
join us tonight for The Bard feature
watch party on the Ramsey shows YouTube
channel uh George and I will not be uh
appearing live
oh that's fair to say as as you know in
the corner somewhere like Mystery
Science Theater you know that there was
some talk of that the director's cut
yeah well honestly I wanted to do it but
George's people wouldn't work with us uh
my people talked to George's people and
we couldn't come together on the whole
deal uh James May show up if there's
free popcorn because he's never turned
out a free meal in his life I do love
some movie in a popcorn you can't beat
that and it's it's an hour and a half
long so you know you'll still make it
before bedtime it's at Seven Central and
seriously get get a crew together get
some friends get the kids and go hey
we're watching this incentivize them if
you have to get him some dinner
beforehand their favorite meal and go
we're gonna watch this and we want to
have a conversation after it's over
would that include TV trays I miss a
good TV trip no don't you well if you're
gonna sit down and watch it yes yeah
bring those back yeah those are great
apparently cloth diapers and cloth baby
wipes are back it's all it's awesome so
we'll bring the TV trays as well so
there you go all right back to the
phones we go Eva joins us in Dayton Ohio
Eva how can we help hello hello how are
you doing oh we're having a blast how
can we I hear you and with the popcorn I
hear you yeah come on Eva what's your
favorite popcorn
pop uh in the big huge pot with some oil
and just let it shake you know yeah come
on well I'm 60 so yeah come on Eva you
put so you're talking about just pouring
the kernels in with the oil Eva gets it
yeah come on uh do you do any salt even
any salt on it no I just do butter just
butter all right all right to each his
own Eva how can we help okay I moved
from Arkansas to Dayton
um when I got a phone when I called home
my mom was crying on the phone
um I get here less than two weeks
after I get home
um
she has an extending aorta aneurysm come
on yeah I wasn't here two weeks and she
passes out of course she sends me to go
get her ice cream and my son is in the
yard and
um my question is I worked in Arkansas
uh worked all the way up until I moved
here and having worked a full-time job
or no job I've just been caring for my
mom because one thing went from shingles
aneurysm to something else to something
else and I'm still caring for her now oh
my uh yeah I get a letter in the mail
yesterday
IRS is telling me I owe them
3764.37 now I need to find out or I need
I need y'all's help yeah sure
and uh do you know what that's referring
to is it clear in the letter it doesn't
say anything in the letter about it it's
just it's like one of those you know how
to payment Internal Revenue Service oh
yeah all right and they try to make it
scary have you verified this
uh
on the whole for about 12 years yeah 100
yeah they don't actually have a human uh
there to help you after they send you a
letter like that it's classic federal
government how are they asking for
payment
here's the biggest part oh now oh here's
the greatest thing on the back page it
says oh if you we can settle this and
not give any interest you will not be to
prevent any interest applicable
penalties from continuing from
continuing pay the amount by November
7th
wow if I had that you know hey I don't
know if this sounds legit I think it
might be a scam
are you serious do they have I would not
pay a dime until I hear from them
directly and you contact them
and so I know that stinks to be on the
phone contact them whatever way you can
because yeah I've tried and tried but I
was on the phone probably I laid the
phone down oh yeah yeah you got to get a
good household project just leave that
thing on hold
oh yeah I've been there you can fold a
couple loads of laundry before they pick
up oh yeah yeah you can wash clothes do
a car all of that yeah did they tell you
what this is for
for an annual reminder about
I don't know if it's legit if after
seven years and you haven't been working
have you been filing any kind of return
do you have any income none none at all
none and it's the little IRS bill you
know the little scales
the eagle I think that's the eagle or
whatever it is nobody knows nobody wants
to look at the IRS let her head long
enough to know what it is well I'll give
you some homework to do either go to
irs.gov help
irs.gov help and there's a there's a
section that says letter from the IRS I
want you to read through that and it
will help you gauge if this is a
legitimate letter from them or not okay
okay but do your homework and don't pay
a dime until you verify this with them
and if you do owe it you got to get this
monkey off your back and you're gonna do
whatever it takes to scrape together the
money and get what about one of our tax
advisors I feel like they could help her
yeah it's worth reaching out to one of
them at ramseysolutions.com and you can
click on our recommended Pros there and
get in touch with a Tax Advisor and see
who will look at this letter and know
whether it's legit number one and then
number two what to do to to to to get
this thing cleared up it feels it feels
very very suspect to me the kids I think
call it sus uh okay yeah there I taught
you a new word Eva you can use that
throw that around with the teens they'll
think you're very cool
so
ramsaysolutions.com yes so on the
recommended Pros yeah yeah it'll say a
it'll say Ramsay recommends okay and you
want a Tax Advisor one of our trusted
Tax Advisor tell them you called the
show and Ken and George think that the
letter is sus and that's all they need
to hear and uh George okay yeah I love
that she's writing this down
and take in some of that fresh popcorn
too
[Laughter]
oh
bless your heart Eva I would not do
anything until we verify verify verify
verify on this I mean people are getting
scammed all the time on this yeah
because when I you know I'm just how are
y'all texting me and I'm not I haven't
filed in seven years well my only
thinking of it was back taxes and
something wasn't right with an old tax
return and they're finally getting
around to it because they're slow as
molasses yeah the last thing that I got
was a refund and that was
seven eight years ago that was probably
about eight years ago
um I got a refund it wasn't it it was a
whole hundred and something dollars
that's all okay well um here's what I
want you to do we want you to uh take
the advice that George gave you there
um with the IRS website Let's see we can
find out there and then if you don't get
any Clarity there I do think it's worth
seeing one of our uh Ramsey trusted tax
advisors to get to the bottom of this
and they will help you get to the bottom
of it very quickly and and efficiently
and uh and then bless your heart for
taking care of your mom I also want to
encourage you to be thinking about some
type of income uh even though you're
watching your mom I want to see you uh
at least be working part-time and try to
be bringing in some income once we get
this thing settled so thank you so much
for calling uh George it's a it's a
scary thing man and and bad people scams
out there bad people play on this stuff
you see anything on other IRS scams well
there's there should be letters there
should be a notice number or a letter
number either the top or bottom right
hand corner of that that will actually
go oh this is legit if it doesn't have
that it's probably fake you absolutely
good stuff there well thank you so much
for the call Eva for the rest of you
don't move we got more of the Ramsey
show coming right up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
and he is George Campbell we're thrilled
to be with you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
Luke 5 16. but Jesus himself would often
slip away to the Wilderness and pray
our quote from Nikola Tesla oh George
this is for you today that has nothing
to do with actual Teslas I know but it's
his last name sure inspired I mean
inspired me to Greatness yeah no the
whole brand is inspired by Tesla come on
you know this his quote be alone that is
the secret of invention be alone that is
when ideas are born do you find that to
be true George I guess I'll leave you to
it then Ken yeah if you could leave the
studio that'd be great no do you find uh
whether it be uh behind the wheel of a
car uh when you think about it some of
the best ideas happen you're on a run
you're in the car you're in the shower
and a great idea happens you know what
it is for me it's uh yard work oh I
should try that sometime well it's
you're allergic to everything but uh the
idea of a monotonous task
um that is so mundane and what happens
is the brain does fire and it just gets
really creative in that time so that is
that is really good advice we don't let
ourselves get bored enough in today's
culture to even get there that's exactly
right you know just alone with your
thoughts is a good thing we need to do
more of that uh all right two Kansas
City Missouri we go Jonathan is there
Jonathan how can we help
all right how you doing Kenny George man
we're having a blast how can we help
yes sir
um my question is we're working at my
job for seven years it's Union so they
have job postings I'm a truck driver
that does delivery driving outside in
the weather and I have an opportunity to
switch to Day times to become where I
only bump docks and deliver and I'm
having trouble with it because I am a
single father which means I would have
to try to find daycare or a babysitter
in the morning okay
um that's a tough one because uh as you
know daycare is very very expensive
uh so what's your situation now who's
watching the kids when you're on the
night shift
right now my mother watches my daughter
and if I can't get off in time uh my
little sister will come pick her up and
I'll just go to my little sister's house
and grab them back enough so what's the
what is the what would the new schedule
be what would the hours be that you need
to cover child care
um the hours are
technically eight to four but with
myself being a truck driver it could go
to eight to six
okay so your daughter is not in school
is that what I'm understanding no no
she's uh only four months right now okay
gotcha
well you know I I wish I had a slick
answer here that was just hey one two
three four this is what you do and I
don't think it's that simple
um because of uh you don't have the
family that can watch the child during
that time and uh does it sound like you
have many options there and then uh
daycare is extremely expensive uh and
that would pretty much put you in a bad
financial situation is that correct
yes it would where are you at right now
financially
uh right now I'm uh currently on baby
step two
um
right yeah baby step two right now how
much debt do you have left
uh I had 50 000 left what kind of debt
is that
um car loans a little bit of student
loans
um and past mistakes I made from
previous marriage and what's your income
income right now is 60 around 60 to 65
000. it will be dropping down to 58
000. uh if I was to take the position
yeah that was my worry is you get a drop
in income and we have to now have extra
expense with child care and so I don't
see how that would work logistically
right now for you it may in the future
once we're out of debt what's the car
worth
uh my car the car or the cars that I
don't have the cars anymore but you said
you had a car loan but you still you
don't have the car but you're still
paying on the loan
uh the loans are right now and um
I'm paying on one of the loans from the
car even though I don't have any more
where's the car so they took me to court
um they they were repossessed oh man and
you got multiple car loans
yes sir yeah I made a lot of bad
mistakes in my past marriage yeah that's
all right we're just trying to help you
create a path forward here what are your
options with the repoed car
um right now one of them uh took me to
court this was before I actually got
connected with you guys so I made a
settlement where I'm paying 250 a month
until it's paid off the other one I
haven't been contacted from them yet but
I know listening to you guys to try to
have some money to where I can settle it
for a cheaper price depending on the
dollar hoping where's the other car
I had neither one of them they're both
repoed oh yeah I don't either oh man and
you're just driving around the truck
right now just for work oh oh no sir I
um saved up and bought me a cash car
okay good I'd like to know what you
would identify as the best way based on
your area and your schedule and what
you'd like to happen for you to make
more money and especially in today's
world where drivers are at a premium
um and I know you can't do over the road
stuff because of the the child but I
just I I wonder how we could make more
money I would be focusing on how can I
raise my income to the point that where
daycare while expensive
would be something that I could offset
and still get out of debt still safe
because I feel like that's going to give
you more freedom in your life too do you
know what I mean where you're not in
this night owl schedule and and not
getting to see your baby and I I just I
want you identifying and looking for
opportunities that may be a lot more
attractive financially for you to where
you can then afford the daycare
yes I've also currently been searching
for other jobs
um and trying to find something that
could also pay me is just like I said
with the trucking business
sometimes there's not really a set time
that's right where you would be well and
to your point to get out of the the
trucking business uh is is something you
need to be looking at we we have wages
at an all-time high right now
um and you know George he's in that 65
000 range you know to be able to make 25
35 an hour in manufacturing and
warehousing right now is very realistic
yeah
um depending on the company depending on
the area uh but to be able to have a set
schedule where you can schedule your
life around I mean this is doable
Jonathan and and um you know you've got
to be at this point going okay I've got
skills and I've got some experience and
I'm not limited to driving a truck
and it feels like there's a little bit
of that on you and
um understand it because it's what you
know
but the reality is is if you think
George you know
what what you know if you're hiring
someone who's going to drive a truck
you're looking for somebody who's
Dependable somebody's going to do what
they're supposed to do show up when it's
supposed to show up there's a lot of
autonomy and that you got to get you
know the car to go that's right but the
ability to work you know in in
manufacturing or warehousing which again
we're seeing jobs explode that's why I'm
specifically mentioning that there's a
lot of the same crossover you don't have
to have a ton of experience you just got
to be Dependable you got to be trainable
teachable coachable yeah and then you
can get a situation where you know to
offset that George what would you say to
someone like him who's in a situation
like that where we go man Child Care is
going to cost x amount a month so salary
after taxes to budget that it is doable
but you're gonna have to increase income
yeah because if we can go from 60 to 80
and even if we use that 20 to cover
Child Care the Gap that still puts us in
a better spot because now he's got a
normal schedule yeah and uh he has
better quality of life and that's
something to consider in all of this too
and absolutely you know life has
happened to Jonathan and that's tough
man when you've been knocked down like
that it's hard to get back up and
believe in yourself and go you know what
I am worth more than this I am going to
go hustle and find another gig but a lot
of even trucking jobs I've been seeing a
lot of bonuses these days and so they're
even jumping to a different company for
a short period of time you might get a
bonus that helps you knock out some of
this debt I'm glad you brought that up
you know maybe in the short term he does
get a trucking another trucking job he's
working that crazy shift but he's got
you know his daughter is currently being
taken care of my family and so what he
does is I'm going to pay off all that
debt I want to fix that then that gives
me some more freedom so a lot of options
there Jonathan keep your head up you can
do this I promise thank you so much for
the call George great hour thanks again
buddy you're so fall festive it seems
wonderful you should go jump at a pile
of leaves after the show we'll be able
to thank the team behind the glass for
keeping us on the air and you America
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]